hey before we dive into today's episode
subscribe to our new channel called your
body on we'll tell you how it would feel
if you won a hot dog eating contest what
it would be like to never sweat again
and much more click on the link below to
find out
your belly button may seem useless but
this passage
once kept you alive
and
this is what remains of the most
profound connection you've ever shared
between you and your mother
so
what would happen if you poked it too
hard and
this piece of your history came undone
what would happen to your organs
would you constantly be leaking fluid
and could you be yourself
oh man someone grab a towel
now please
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you could untie your belly
button
while you as a fetus developed inside
your mother's womb your two bodies were
attached through this
the umbilical cord
able to grow up to 70 centimeters this
tube fed nutrients to you from the
placenta
and after you were born a doctor clamped
and cut the cord leaving you with this
scar
it's useless now but without this tiny
bit of flesh
your body would fall apart
but if you have an audi belly button are
your organs already at risk
a small number of people have
omphalophobia
the fear of belly buttons
so for those people let's clear
something up
your belly button isn't the knot
it just looks coiled up but it's a scar
so nothing can come unraveled
but it could get dissolved
and if it did an infection could run
rampant throughout your body
and
now you can be afraid
in this area you can find direct links
to the liver and the bladder
if these connections to your organs
became exposed an infection could be
lethal
so
what could make this area fall apart
well if the umbilical cord didn't heal
properly the tissue could wear down over
time
and if that happened your audi belly
button could start to leak
yeah
and if you think having an innie is any
better well keep watching
in most cases an audi belly button is
the natural result of the tissue healing
in this protruding shape
some women have their navel flatten or
even stick out further during pregnancy
due to the pressure building within
their bodies
their innies could balloon into audis
but for infants this could be a sign of
an umbilical hernia
their intestines and body fat pushing
through the stomach muscles under the
belly button
this condition usually heals itself
after the baby is over 18 months but if
you live with this abnormality it would
leave your skin red
swollen and oozing with pus
yeah good luck getting that pierced
when you were a baby you had a canal
between your bladder and belly button
which usually disappears when you get
older but in rare instances this canal
can remain and it can cause urine to
leak out of your navel
a surgery after birth can repair this
condition but if your belly button
unraveled you could be leaking urine all
the time oh man it's everywhere
now you may think your life is the only
one on the line but if you had an innie
you could have up to 67 different
species of bacteria in your belly button
biologists studying the relationship
between humans and bacteria could even
create cheese from the microbes living
inside here
and a cheese made from your belly button
could taste different than anyone else's
cheese
let me explain that researchers studying
dozens of belly buttons found that some
people had bacteria unique to them
there could be microbes on your body
that can't be found anywhere else in the
universe
but with the constant infections and
treatments you would endure
you could eradicate entire species of
bacteria in your body forever
after you're born this tissue doesn't
have a vital function anymore but if it
disappeared
you and everything around you would be a
complete mess with all these fluids
draining out of you what would happen
next
what if your stomach acid disappeared
well put those nachos down and listen up
because
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]